حسنا اعلنا حزب القوات اللبنانيه والكتائب
وكتل البرلمانيه ونواب مستقلون عن ترشيح
الوزيره السابق جهاد ازعور لرئاسه
الجمهوريه اللبنانيه
عن هذه القوه اعلن المرشح لرئاسه
اللبنانيه ميشال معوض انسحابه لصالح ازعور
كما اكد المجتمعون توافقهم مع التيار
الوطني الحر برئاسه جبران باسيل على ترشيح
ازعور واشاروا لانه شخصيه وسطيه غير
استفزازيه
وقد طالب حزباء القوات اللبنانيه والكتائب
وكتل برلمانيه ونواب مستقلون رئيس المجلس
النيابي اللبناني نبي ببر بعقد جلسه
برلمانيه
وقال النائب مارك ضو متحدثا باسم هذه
القوه بعد ترشيحها الوزير السابق جهاد
زعور لرئاسه الجمهوريه قال ان اليد ممدوده
الى حزب الله وحركه امل لانقاذ الوطن لكن
هذه القوه متاهبه في الوقت عينه لمواجهه
كل مخططات التعطيل حسب تعبيره
ان قوى المعارضه التي اجتمعه اجتمع
ممثلوها اليوم
تدعو باقي الزملاء النواب وخاصه رئيس
المجلس النيابي نبيه بري الى دعوه لالتئام
الجلسه واجب انعقادها فورا بحسب الدستور
دون اي ابطاء لانتخاب رئيس للجمهوريه في
جلسات متتاليه يدنا ممدوده للطلاق حول هذا
الطرح مع القوه السياسيه لاسيما حزب الله
حركه امل ومن بقي من حلفائهم
ومتاهبون في الوقت عينه لمواجهه كل مخططات
التعطيل
[موسيقى]